Позаду - так звана"ЛНР", під ногами - провалля.
Через цей хиткий міст доведеться перейти мешканцям окупованої Луганщини,
які захочуть проголосувати на виборах до Верховної Ради.
І то - двічі: один раз - щобзмінити місце голосування, і один - щоб віддати голос.
Тож,не дивно, що більшість із нихголосувати не планують.
Утім, за українською політикою слідкують, а на нову владу покладають великі надії.
Хочуть насамперед миру - домовлятися готові хоч з Путіним, хоч із ватажками так званих"ЛНР"і"ДНР".
Тільки переговорами - між Росією, Україною і невизнаними республіками.
Шляхом переговорів.
А з ким?
Мабуть, з Росією. Місцеве керівництво, я думаю, без згоди Росії нічого не вирішує.
До чого тут Путін? Це, я вважаю, українська проблема.
Домовитися з Луганськом - і все. Прийти, побудувати школи, дороги в Луганську.
Щоб все було добре. А то все розвалене,і ніхто нічого не ремонтує.
Надію на мирбагато громадян по обидві лінії фронту
пов’язують із нещодавнім розведенням сил біля Станиці Луганської.
Домовилися про це ще у2016 році. Проте плани постійно зривалися через порушення перемир’я.
Лише наприкінці червня цього року українська армія і проросійські сепаратисти
на кілометр відійшли від передових позицій.
Окремі укріплення ЗСУ вже навіть демонтували.
Інші поки залишили - чекають на відповідні кроки противника.
Військові кажуть - обстрілів поки немає.
Сподіваємося, що за цим сценарієм все йтиме і надалі.
Що ворог все-таки відійде, припинить обстріли,
що ворога не будуть підтримувати інші країни.І все ж таки буде мир в Україні.
Я взагалі вірю в мир. А як ми цього досягнемо, це вже політичне питання. Головне, щоб він настав.
На камеру військові запевняють - про відступ не йдеться, а нові позиції навіть кращі за попередні.
Втім, не всі мешканці Станиці Луганської поділяють такий оптимізм.
Передусім проукраїнські активісти і біженці з так званої "ЛНР",
яких тут чимало,бояться,що сепаратисти порушать домовленості.
66-річна Наталя Журбенко п’ять років томубула змушена з родиною тікативід бойовиків.
У рідному Луганську втратила житлоі бізнес.
На новому місці стала військовою волонтеркою,а згодом депутаткою районної ради.
Ось бачите -всі дерева повалені.Це називається місячний пейзаж -"руський мир"прийшов.
У 2014 році це місце називали "Сталінградом". Тут були передові позиції української армії.
Наталя Журбенко, яка після втечі з Луганська оселилася у дачному селищі поблизу,
була свідком запеклих боїв, що точилися тут, допомагала військовим як волонтерка.
Каже - після побаченого у домовленості з Росією та сепаратистами вже не вірить.
Хіба це крок до миру? Сісти за стіл переговорів з тими, хто п’ять років нас обстрілював?
Як тоді досягти миру?
Тільки завдяки світовій спільноті. Санкціями.
Чи стане розведеннясил у Станиці Луганській дійсно поштовхом для миру,
чи залишиться лише епізодом війни, яка триває вже понад п’ять років - говорити ще рано.
Адже бойові дії на інших ділянках фронту не вщухають.
Утім, для мешканців Луганщини принаймні з’явилася реальна надія
на відновлення мосту через лінію зіткнення.
Це їм пообіцяв президент Володимир Зеленський.
Проте можливим це стане тільки тоді, коли сепаратисти приберуть свої укріплення.